hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar
incorporation and
automation of rna scope technology
into your covid19 viral
pathogenesis genesis research
i am sabrina lemmons of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
labruz and brought to you by leica
biosystems and biotechnic
to learn more about our sponsors please
visit leica biosystems and biotechny.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions that
we
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speakers geode
sheldon
andrea de baeze damien cockfield
for complete biographies on our speakers
please visit the speaker biographies tab
at the top of your screen deyote you may
now begin your presentation
thank you so much for joining the
webinar today
my name is jody sheldon i work as an
application scientist at advanced cell
diagnostics
and i'm going to go over today what are
the different novel applications of rna
scope
and how you can apply the irony scope
assay
in your coven 19 research so we're going
to learn about incorporating
this highly sensitive and specific
technology
for your coven 19 viral pathogenesis
research
on the agenda today i'm going to cover
the technology itself
i'm going to go over our kobit 19
product offerings
and then i'd like to show you some
examples of the publications
that have come out showing how
researchers have used this technology
uh in their covid19 research
so to begin with what is the rna scope
in c2 hybridization technology
the iron scope assay is a highly
specific and sensitive method and that
is the value prop of the assay
this assay allows a method that allows
you to detect rna biomarkers
in cells and in tissues while really
giving you that morphological context
that spatial analyses
something that you miss with a lot of
other traditional
transcriptomic techniques it is a
hybridization based
signal amplification system with a
unique probe design
that allows for simultaneous signal
amplification
as well as background suppression the
technology consists of
three parts the first part is a unique
target probe
that advanced cell diagnostic designs
against your sequence of interest
the second is a signal amplification
system
that generates a high signal to noise
ratio
and lastly you can visualize your data
as a single rna molecule
punctate dot this assay allows for
spatial mapping of various types of rnas
such as mrnas link rnas
splice variants highly homologous
sequences
and point mutations in both cells and in
intact tissues
all of which can either be visualized
using a fluorescent or a chromogenic
label
the acid can be performed on a wide
variety of sample type
including ffpe tissues frozen tissues
you can also run the acid on pbmcs
as well as cultured cells
so how does the technology work the two
key features of the iron scope
technology
are probe designed at signal
amplification
the oligonucleotide target specific
probes
that you design are depicted as the zs
to emphasize the fact that they have two
regions
linked by a spacer the bottom of the z
complements and hybridizes to the target
sequence your audio sequence of interest
while the top of the z is the base for
an amplification structure
when the two z is hybridized in tandem
to the target sequence
it creates a binding site upon which a
pre-amplifier
can bind and an amplification tree can
build
now after these z-pres hybridize with
the target rna
the preamplifier binds to the top of the
z and then the
preamplifier can bind multiple
amplifiers
and further each of these amplifiers can
bind multiple label probes
these labeled probes contain either a
chromogenic enzyme
or a fluorophore that generates a signal
detectable under a standard right field
microscope
or a fluorescent microscope this signal
amplification strategy
yields a high sensitivity and allows for
visualization of target rnas
as a single dot so now you may ask how
do we get that specificity
the specificity of the assay comes from
these two different z's
you need both of these z's to bind in
tandem
for the amplification tree to be built
and to see a signal
just a single d binding to a
non-specific site will result in no
signal
and so with the combination of this
sensitivity and specificity
you end up getting that high signal to
noise ratio which makes this technology
really really good for different kinds
of mrna targets
we have a variety of product portfolios
of both the ionoscope and the base scope
assays
i won't go into too much detail as my
colleague andrea will
talk a little bit more about it but in a
nutshell we have both
chromogenic and fluorescent assays that
can either be performed manually
or using our automated platforms such as
the leica platform
the two new assays that came out in the
last two years was the high place assay
that allows for detection of up to 12
targets
as well as the micro rna scope acid the
base scope assay allows you to take
shorter targets
so it really covers a broad portfolio of
different targets that you can visualize
so now let's go a little bit more over
how why is iron scope-ish
ideal for viral detection how
what is the value prop of rna scope for
researchers that are studying viruses
so i try to break this down into
different kind of categories
right the characteristic feature of this
technology
enables one to overcome the various
challenges
that researchers face in detection of
viruses
let's start with the context this in c2
hybridization assay can be
used with various sample types such as
the ffpe
frozen and fixed frozen as i mentioned
before
that allows for detection of practically
any target
while providing you that morphological
information
along with that viral localization this
can help researchers identify
entry portals replication sites disease
sites
therefore further understanding the
viral dynamics
next we go to sensitivity as i mentioned
before the preamplifier
and the amplifier tree system is built
to enable
for high sensitivity that allows you to
detect
low viremia this helps in detecting
viruses at very early stages of
infection
and latent stages that present lower
transcripts
and often present difficulties in
detecting these viruses
with some of the other traditional
techniques
the specificity as i also talked about
before the patented
zz technology or the double d technology
provides high specificity of the
assay what this allows you to do is
discern
closely related viral species giving the
sequence is known that
the if you know the sequence of the gene
that you're looking for
acd can design a probe for practically
any species
this design process is rapid which
serves as a huge advantage for emerging
viruses
without available antibodies for example
the kobit 19.
the probes can be designed either single
stranded or can be made strand specific
to discern between various viral stages
with hybridization to both the sense
and the anti-sense strand and this
really allows you to look at both the
replicating strand as well as the viral
strand in the same tissue context
giving your data a lot of power
so iron scope has an ability to detect a
wide range of viral species
you can look at dna viruses rna viruses
retrotranscribing viruses the focus
today of course is going to be
discovered 19 species
so now i'd like to go over some of the
kobit 19 offerings
what are some of the products that acd
offers right now
for enabling your kovin-19 research this
is a really good image that shows kind
of like that brought
off range you can first detect the virus
itself
by using our kovin-19 a probe that
targets the
spike protein you can also further your
research by looking at the virus
receptor interaction by doing a duplex
or a multiplex assays
in addition we as we all know carbon 19
infection
follows up with this immune response and
so you can also look at the
virus receptor as well as the immune
response that follows with this inspect
um infection using a multiplex assays
or as they call the cytokine storm and
in addition we've also seen a lot of
researchers use rna scope
to look at various histopathological
markers
at the at the tissue of infection or the
infection site
so it really allows you to look at this
whole mechanistic action or the whole
pathogenesis from how the virus infects
the body
to what receptors it interacts with and
what is the body's response to that
infection
so what is our coronavirus probe
information
the standard coronavirus probe that acd
offers is this the encode 2019
s probe it is available and it targets
that coronavirus outbreak that first
happened in wuhan china in 2019
this probe was designed specifically to
detect that spike as
protein of this novel virus once again
going back to the specificity
it was designed such that it avoids
cross-detection
with some of the other star species the
tsars the mers and other coronavirus
family species
the probe can be used in a wide variety
of animal models
such as the human the mouse rat
monkey potential natural hosts such as
ferret fat etc
this probe can be used to study
localization as well as infiltration of
the virus in different tissues
based on the data that has been
published since the emergence of this
covate19 virus
this given list of rna-scope probes are
now made available
ready to use for customers to study the
pathophysiology of the source
virus i already talked a little bit
about this before the product offerings
but these are the actual targets
that are already designed for you to
order and use in your
research studies for viral detection we
have both the source cov2
as well as the sarsko v2 sense probe
that allows you to now
look at both the viral strand as well as
the replicating strand
again the host cell markers is a lot of
you may know some of the early host cell
markers that were studied with sarsko v2
were the ace 2 tempras 2 and cathepsin
bnl
the cytokine stone markers are the
inflammatory response markers such as
the il markers
tns alpha and the mip1 alpha
and the other thing i mentioned about is
a lot of pathologists or scientists out
there also want to look at the actual
pathophysiology
and so they look at these
histopathological markers like
aquaphorin 5
rage and 16 in the lung tissue
in addition to studying these ionoscope
markers alone
you can also combine institute
hybridization using ionoscope
along with an antibody for isc this
workflow has already been established
you can
reach out to our support team and they
can provide you more details on that
the way you would do this is you would
perform the iron scope assay first
and follow it by performing your ifc or
immunofluorescent staining
these are just some of the potential
combinations or the different ways you
can do this
you can perform the ish assay for the
viral
probe and then you can perform an
antibody scanning for the receptor probe
depending on what
and what is you already have available
or you're using in your lab
so with all of these product offerings
that that acd provides you and all these
various techniques that you can use
i'd like to now show you some of the
examples of
early papers as well as new papers of
how
researchers in the field are actually
using the irony scope assay
to enable their covid19 research
so this first paper i want to talk to
you about is basically
the understanding of protected immunity
to this sars kobe 2
is very critical for vaccine development
and for public health strategies
that are aimed to end this global
pandemic so a key unanswered question at
that time was
whether infection with this virus
results in a protective immunity against
re-exposure
basically if a person is infected will
this person develop a protective
immunity
in this paper scientists from harvard
medical school they developed a recessed
macaque model for sarskovi ii
to study the pathological and
immunological findings of covid19
they also used this model to study the
natural immunity
against sarskov2 after re-exposure
the ironiscope chromogenic red acetate
was used to visualize
the sarcove-2 viral rna in the lung
tissue
along with the detection of its
replicating intermediate
so they basically wanted to look at both
the replicating strand as well as the
viral strand on the same tissue context
in addition to looking at the
chromogenic acid
they also use the fluorescent assay to
look at the
source covey2 strand but in addition to
that they performed
antibody scanning for both the the virus
as well as the nucleotoxic protein
the key message here is that rna scope
enables the visualization of viral
replication in the respiratory tract
of these models that can be further used
for testing vaccines as well as
therapeutics which is an emerging market
in the field right now
this next paper came out of university
of north carolina from the beric lab
the mode of acquisition and causes for
the variable clinical spectrum
of covid90 disease remains unknown
scientists in this study they used a
reverse genetic system to study sarskovi
to growth
as well as pathogenesis now they use
scope in two different sample types they
use it on cytospin
samples as well as in tissue samples
the technology using this rna scope
technology we revealed that ace to
expression
in upper respiratory tract with
increased sensitivity
and efficacy compared to single cell rna
sequencing
they used the iron scope chromogenic red
assay
and established an ace-to-expression
gradient in the respiratory tract
and detected temperatures to enormous
human
surface airway epithelium
to gain insight into pathways that might
contribute to the dysregulation of
acetyl-expression
in cystic fibrosis lungs they also
tested the effects of selected cytokines
on ace to expression in large airway
epithelial cultures
inner linking 1b the dominant pro-mucin
secretory cytokine in cystic fibrosis
and non-cystic fibrosis secretion
upregulated ace2
but did not upregulate temperature
this next paper came out of u.s ambride
and this was one of those early papers
where scientists were trying to identify
and evaluate commercially available
reagents
and acids from molecular detection of
sars cov2
in infected ffpe cell pellets now
these researchers they tested multiple
ifc antibodies
along with rna scope-ish assay for viral
detection
and infected african green monkey kidney
cells
in this first image you'll see that
they've used the ischool chromogenic
acid
to look at both the viral rna as well as
its replicating strand in ffpe cell
pellets
but in addition they also tested the
iron scope multiplex fluorescent assay
to visualize viral rna again in both
uninfected as well as infected cells
and they saw a strong signal of both the
viral s
protein in the and the replicating
strand in the infected tissue
once again really emphasizing the
sensitivity of this acid
in the same paper lastly they show the
adoption of our dualish ifc technique
that i talked about earlier
in this paper they combined both the
iron scope
sarskovi ii probe as well as its
antibody in the same tissue section
to simultaneously visualize both rna and
protein
truly highlighting the power of this
dualish ifc technique
this particular publication came out of
medical center of hamburg
severe acute respiratory syndrome or the
tsarskov2
preferentially infects cells in the
respiratory tract as we all know
but it's direct affinity for other
organs in the lung
remains poorly understood researchers
are still trying to understand
how this infection affects other uh
organs of the tissue body
in this study researchers present data
from an autopsy series of 27 patients
that show that sarcoscope 2 can be
detected in multiple organs
some of them including the lungs pharynx
heart
liver brain and kidneys nowadays show
a strong association between more than
two coexisting conditions in patients
and source cova to tropism in the
kidneys
they detected the sarcome to viral rna
with spatial resolution
in tissues that were tested positive
with pcr
they were ffpe lung and renal parenchyma
samples
and they used the irony scope red assay
for this
their results indicated that sars cov2
had an organotropism beyond the
respiratory tract
including the kidneys liver heart and
brain
and that organotropism may influence the
course of this covid19 disease
and possibly aggravate some of the
pre-existing conditions
in the patients that were infected with
this virus
there has been conflicting data about
the possibility of vertical transmission
of this
sarcoidovirus from a mother to baby in
the womb
in this particular study luisa patani
and other researchers
studied two cases that were sourced
called two pcr-positive mothers
uh for in the neonate and placenta now
they use the
uh rnas called brown acid on the leica
platform
to visualize the virus in the placental
tissue
in addition to evaluating the tissue
distribution
but they could do all of that while
still retaining that morphological
context
the assay validated the presence of the
sars cov2rna
in the infected placentas supporting the
possibility of a vertical transmission
from a source covey of stars kovichi
from a mother to a baby
in utero
now this image was from arcana labs and
yale school of medicine
again related to that whole pregnancy
outcomes where researchers presented a
case
of covid19 positive patient who was in
her second trimester
that was complicated by severe
preeclampsia and placental abortion
abruption
now they wanted to distinguish between
the physiological effects of
preeclampsia
and coping 19 for better prognosis of
pregnancy
they used the iron skull brown assay to
visualize the sars cov22rna in the
placental tissue
they also saw that the sarskovitu rna
staining pattern
closely matched that of the h2 receptor
pattern
as seen on the human protein atlas
this last paper was one of the early
papers that came out of chinese academy
of medical sciences
plenty of diagnostic preventive and
therapeutic knowledge
on the virus was enriched from clinical
studies since december of 2019
however at that time animal models and
particularly
non-human primate models were urgently
needed for critical questions
that could not be answered in clinical
patients
is that for evaluation of antiviral
drugs and vaccines
so the researchers in this study they
evaluated various families of non-humane
primates
to identify an accurate model to study
the infection
they found that the end mulatto was most
susceptible to the infection compared to
the m vascularis and the c jacobs
arnesco fluorescent assay was used to
visualize
the sarcoid 2x protein rna in infected
non-human primate tissues to detect
different degrees of viral distribution
in different tissues this particular
paper is actually a really good example
of a probe design
this paper came out very early this year
when
not a lot of antibodies were available
and the rapid probe design technology of
rna scope assay allows you to design
for any particular species out there as
long as the sequence is known
so with a lot of these publications out
there we have seen that the growth and
adoption of the ionoscope technology
is best exemplified by the number of our
peer review publications
our first publication came in 2011 and
since then
there have been over 2700 peer reviewed
papers
using iron scope technology in numerous
journals
including many of the top tier ones it
is highly relevant across multiple
fields of research
although this particular presentation
concentrates on infectious diseases and
covid19
you can also apply this technology for
in areas such as cancer
neuroscience stem cells development
inflammation and
and many many more so with all of that
i hope i've convinced you today and to
summarize that the rna scope assay
uses a unique probe design strategy to
dramatically
improve the signal to noise ratio we
currently have over 22 000 probes in
catalog for various applications
but new probes can be designed and made
within two weeks for any target
and any species the arnesco provides
both quantitative and spatial
information on your targets
in the complex tissue environment at a
single cell resolution
the newest assay base scope can detect
splicing variants
and short sequences down to 15
nucleotides
and that the rna scope assay can be
complemented with ifc
or immunofluorescence for simultaneous
rna and protein detection
on the same slide with that i come to
the end of my part of the presentation
but i would like to give the cue to my
co-worker andrea
and he will go over the application of
rna scope on the leica platform
thank you so much and if you have any
questions please ask them at the end of
the presentation thank you
[Music]
hi everyone thank you for attending this
webinar
i'm a field application specialist for
acd located in the los angeles area
and today i'm going to present you our
rna scope technology and how it can be
used
on the leica bond rx i know jody already
gave you a more detailed introduction to
the rna scope technology
so i will briefly say only the following
rna scope is an situ hybridization
technology that will allow you to detect
and quantify a nucleic acid target
inside a cell in a morphological intact
tissue using the microscope
it provides detection quantification and
mostly morphological context
of your targets it consists of three
parts
the first one is the rna scope probe
which we provide and is designed for a
specific target
we have thousands of probes available
for many targets and many species
if we don't have one we can make it as
long as you can provide us with a target
sequence to work with
the second part is the rna scope essay
which includes all the amplifiers
pre-amplifiers and reagents necessary in
general for building the
signal on top of the probe so that it
can be visualized
finally the third part is the image of
imaging of your sample under the
microscope and the visualization of the
rna scope signal which consists
of dots where each dot represents a
target
the location and number of dots tell you
about how much
and where your target is expressed
an important thing to know about this
workflow in general is that
when done manually at the bench it takes
approximately one to two days
depending on the type of essay a single
plex
essay may take a day a fluorescent
essay four plus may take up to two days
so uh basically having access to
the leica bond rx or rxm it's
a great asset because the major feature
of this technology is that it can run up
to
30 slides completely unattended
the run is approximately 10 hours 11
hours we generally
run it overnight and it's designed to
process mostly
samples prepared as ffp samples formally
fixed paraffin embedded but it can also
process
fixed and fresh frozen samples it just
takes a little bit more
planning
before i get into the uh details
of the um rna scope on the leica bond
i want to give you a quick overview of
the portfolio of the rna scope assets
that we provide that can be used only
like a bond
so the rna scope assays that we provide
that are available
are the singleplex brown
and singleplex red rna scope assays
the singleplex brown uses hrp as an
enzyme and dab as a substrate to give
you a brown pigment
the rna scope red is giving you instead
a red
dot a red pigment and it's using
alkaline phosphatase as an enzyme and
fast red as a substrate
they are both single plexus so they both
detect
only one target and they're perfectly
compatible with the
leica bond rx system the other type of
essay that we offer
is the rna scope duplex the duplex essay
will allow you to detect
two targets at the same time in the
slide
one is gonna be one color and one is
gonna be another color
so you're gonna need two probes
rna-scope probes respectively known
with with a different channel um that's
a topic that will be explained better
by technical support if you need to and
if you wish to run this as say entirely
on the instrument
you can you can also use you can use
only the
red and brown pigments but you have the
options to do the red pigment on the
instrument
and if you prefer to have the second
signal as a green
dot that can be done offline it's a
very fast procedure down at the bench
immediately after the run
so brown and red online on the
instrument
and red and green offline only for the
green part
the other rna scope essay that we offer
that is used
a lot with the leica system is the
multiplex fluorescent
sa rn scope assay it will allow you to
detect to
up to four targets at the same time but
you know
of course detect less targets you will
need to get
fluorescent dyes from known as also tsa
plus
dyes or opal dyes from aquarium
biosciences
and you will need to have one two up to
two
to four um rna scope probes they all
have to be different channels so there
is no crosstalk
and this procedure again is perfectly
compatible with the leica bond rx
then the other two assets that we offer
are the basic
essay and the micro rna scope assay the
base scope assay is a single plex
type of assay for the detection of their
of
very short sequences down to 50 base
pairs
so if you have a very small target
because the region
nearby it's not known or is too
conserved in the genome
or if you have an exon exon junction or
something
just simply very small to detect and you
cannot do it with a conventional rna
scope i say
because that one covers a 1kb
region you can use the base scope essay
that's because all covers only 50 base
pairs
this is offered for the leica bond
as a singleplex red option
and that's same and the newly born
from in the acd company product is a
micro rna scope essay that will allow
you to detect
uh micro rnas uh using uh the red
chemistry just
like the single black thread
so regarding the uh detection
of covet um
virus um the virus type code is coded as
you as we
as you well know covid is um involves
a wide variety it's a quite
it's quite a complex mechanism that uh
involves having the virus attacking the
host cell
and when that happens uh we have uh
um the viral genome
and then we have the the production of
a replicating strand inside the host
cell
and the downstream cascade of events is
basically a big inflammatory response
and of course the disease that we all
know as the cov19 disease
this mechanism involves a wide variety
of
targets and we do offer them as part of
our portfolio
as an rna scope product so we have
several different probes that will allow
you to detect
the um the virus strength the positive
strand of the virus
we have probes that will allow you to
detect the replicating strand inside the
cell
we have two types of probes for the
replicating strand
one that is exactly complementary to the
positive strand and one that is instead
not complementary it's just a little bit
downstream the region that will allow
you to do duplexing
and then we have probes of course that
are available for the detection of the
markers and the targets that usually are
involved in this mechanism like the ac2
category and so on and of course all the
inflammatory genes
these probes are available you can go to
our website if you go on the top right
side
you can click on search and basically
you can type the name of the target that
you wish to detect
and the example that you see here on
this slide is
for one of the probes it's for the
replicating strength
and when you go to each probe
specification page you can see
exactly what is detecting where this
probe has been designed the accession
number
the target region as you can see here
that's exactly where the z
pro the c the z probes are binding and
the length
of this probe in this case is the 40
base pair region
so you get to see for each probe
involved in the uh
copying 19 mechanism the specification
of the design of the probe
now these probes are available
for the rna scope as an rna scope essay
on
system acd offers two product
configurations for running
rna scope on the leica system one is the
ls
reagent and the other one
is the nsx reagent the question is
how do they differ i'll start with the
simplest one
the lsx product configuration is
available only
for the singleplex brown rna scope and
singleplex
red this configuration the
lsx is the most user friendly
the user does not need to transfer any
reagent
from the act values or bottles into the
leica containers everything is already
pre-packaged at the factory in the leica
containers
the reagents are already loaded onto the
software we'll see that a little bit
later and all the user need to do is to
simply slide
these trays the reagent trays into the
instrument
loads the instrument with the slides and
of course the user needs to scan these
sparkles that you see on this trace but
that's a very simple
action you scan the barcode and you
click and you say okay
on the screen and that's simply that's
it you basically just
run the instrument and for 10 hours
you're going to have your instrument
running
from beginning to the end this is the
simplest and fastest and most convenient
type of configuration the lsx which as i
said earlier
is available only for red and brown
single plex canisters
we do have the ls product configuration
which instead is available for more rna
scope assays
it is available for the brown and red
single plates just like the lsx
but it's also available for the duplex
rna scope assays the fluorescent
multiplexes the base scope
and the microarranged scope assays so
there is a
wider portfolio there are more options
the difference though respect to the ls
sets is that it's not as user friendly
that being said is very easy to set it
up
the reagents are coming from our company
in a box
and they are in bottles and all you need
to do
what the user needs to do is to transfer
these reagents
in the appropriate containers the
containers must be obtained
from leica and just like other reagents
for running the instrument must be
obtained for leica so this is
the running of an ls rna scope
experiment is done with reagents that
are coming from both companies of course
so the only convenience is basically the
loading of the containers
um which is not pre-packaged and
one important thing to know is which is
very nice is that the none of these
reagents needs
need to be warmed up before loading
um the running of
the experiment on the instrument of
course being an instrument
has is connected to a computer and is
driven by a software i just want to
spend a little bit of time on the
software and tell you that currently
the leica software is the 6.0 version
there are other versions out there
mostly the 5.2 and the 4.0
um i recommend you to update if possible
because the 6.0 is the version that
offers the
um it's extremely user friendly
you get to see here a quick screenshot
on the far right of the slide
it's very user friendly because it will
allow you to
create and customize
the protocol in a very easy way you can
choose between open and closed washes
you can choose the temperature of
incubation
the time and what what items need to be
added to your protocol you can do these
things also
in the older versions it's just not as
user friendly
all rna scope assets can run on the
version 6.0
so no worries about what you can run on
this version
the only one you need to be aware is the
newest
micro rna capacities that can run only
on the 6.0 and cannot be
run on the older version so if you have
the 6.0 you're basically
perfectly safe and you can go ahead
um there is another important thing
in addition to the software version that
a user needs to be aware of and that
would be
the um the data version
uh what we call more simply as bdz
version
ls rna scope assays require bdz11
type of data version if you wish to run
the very user-friendly nfx red and brown
chemistry
you need the bbz version 15 or above
and if you are running our most recent
microarrays capacity you need the btc 20
or above
so when you go to your software please
go to the
um section where you can look what type
and version of software you have like
you see here on the screen
and be sure that look at the data
version number
and be sure that it's compatible with
the rnas capacity that you want to
run all right let's look
very quickly at the workflow and how it
works
this is not meant to be a training did
we do this on site
in your lab with one of us uh we come to
your lab in other words but i'm just
i'm going to give you anyway a quick
overview um
the running an rna scope essays
basically involves the following steps
the first step is to add
reagents to the software the software
comes with a series of reagents already
pre-programmed at the factory
all these reagents have an asterisk nest
next to them
so you know what hardwired at the
factory
some of these reagents can be used for
rna scope
some others are not usable or better are
not there
to run rna scope the user can easily
generate them
so you need to do what we call uh user
made
reagents all these reagents will not
have an asterisk connects to them
and you can give them a name um just be
aware you cannot
rename a reagent twice with the same
name you need to change the name a
little bit and
just as a reminder if you're working
with the lsx reagents
you do not need to do any of these
but anyway you will need to add and
generate some reagents pertaining to the
rnas capacities that you want to run
the next step will be to set up the
protocol
so the protocol is basically a set of
instructions that the
machine needs to have in order to
execute a specific workflow
in this protocol you have the reagents
you generated
and you have also the timings and the
temperatures at which these
steps need to be executed protocols just
like reagents
some of them are pre-made at the factory
all of the pre-made ones come
with an asterisk next to it um
if you need to make a protocol and you
will need to make a protocol those will
not have an asterisk
is next to it and you can name them
whatever you want you just cannot use
the name
twice again if you're running the lsx
chemistry you do not need to worry about
generating the protocol and just to
give you a little bit more of a detailed
explanation on what it means to make a
protocol you basically what you need to
do
is open a pre-made preset protocol
that is already on the leica system like
in this case the acd 2.5 eab
revision b protocol which you can see
here
um and modify it according to the user
manual that you have in front of you
when corresponding to a specific rna
scope
assay the modifications that you need to
do are basically in front of your eyes
you need to be sure that all those steps
that you see on the far right of the
of the slide are there that the reagent
that is listed is that exactly that one
and that the incubation times
temperature times and washes whether
they're open or closed and so on
are exactly as per um
applying in the protocol table once you
are done
making the modifications then you can
save the protocol and you can use it in
the future multiple times
so this is mostly a one-time thing that
you need to do
and let me remind you that we do this
for you
the field application specialist from
hcd
will come to your lab and generate the
protocol for you
and we do as many protocols as you think
you might need
if down the road you need more you can
try to do it yourself or we can come
back and do it for you
but basically making a protocol involves
taking an existing protocol
edited modified so that it can run
properly the rna is called
assets once the protocol is made the
next step
is to basically register
the reagents and that means you're
you're scanning the containers with the
reagent
so that the instrument can link a
certain container to a certain reagent
present on the protocol that's very
important and it's done with a
scanner and once you're done
you have done this you basically um you
can start
setting up your experiment you're gonna
click on slide
setup tab like it's shown here on the
slide
subsequently you're gonna give a name to
your project or study
here is where you're going to decide
whether you need the big
nd wax um steps those are necessary when
you're using
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded slides
if you don't have
those kind of slides um you can omit it
and then you're gonna click on okay and
then
you're gonna add for each slide a name
and a pro name so you're basically
giving to the software
information about every slide and every
slide is characterized by
a sample name and a problem for sure
then of course to that slide a certain
protocol is applied a protocol that you
made
including all the pretreatment
conditions which are the two things you
are going to mostly work with
and modify in order to optimize your
essay
once you're done adding a slide the
slides get added in the computer in the
software
and finally you are ready to print out
the labels
the labels will go on the slides on the
glass slides
and then you're going to load the
instrument this is a quick overview of
the instrument
it's like a bond uh you have bulk
reagents at the bottom just be sure the
reagents there is enough
to run the number of slides that you
want to run
if you don't uh have enough instrument
we'll tell you the software will
complain and tell you
then you're going to load the trays into
the instrument
and uh
the trace that you can load are three
there are three slots you can
load up to three different trays each
tray
can host the 10 slides and
on the far right of the instrument you
are going to
load up the trade with the reagents
and that's where all the reagents are
and at that point you're ready to run
and at the end of the day or all
as i said it's an overnight run you're
going to have your slide
completely stained all you need to do is
just cover sleeve them
uh regarding some full preparation
for the kobe detection um it
actually it doesn't really matter much
whether you're detecting a target
related to the kobe disease or not
um this is the typical sample
preparation that we recommend
for any black tissue that is formally
fixed paraffin embedded so we recommend
to have it fixed
for between 16 and 32 hours we recommend
to
cut it at a thickness approximately of 5
microns we recommend you to use
and put your tissues on positively
charged
slides and when
once you're done you can slow sawyer's
life
in a second at room temperature
and use them please within three months
all right in regards to the
pre-treatment conditions
those are basically uh very important
because it's where you're going to do
the majority of your optimization
so the workflow runs a series of steps
that are pretty much
set in stone but before that you need to
decide
how long and how warm is your target's
retrieval step will be
and what type of protease you will use
and for how long and
at what temperature that's where you're
gonna do your optimization so
in the protocol in the software you can
choose
target retrieval known as epitope
retrieval which
on the software appears with the letters
h-i-e-r
here uh and there you can choose between
88 degrees or 95 degrees
uh and how many minutes for the protease
detection
usually we don't really play much with
that but
in case you need to especially if you're
using
fixed frozen or fresh frozen tissue then
um that would be uh the option usually
are to use
either the protease three or the
proteins four
so of the protein s4 which is a stronger
protein
it is it's an option and
finally to give you a quick uh summary
um i can say this the rna scope passes
are available to run on the like a
system you can run
up to 30 slides efficiently and
completely unattended
brown and red chemistry singleplex are
available
in lfx format extremely user-friendly
i call it plug-and-play workflow um
brown red duplex multiplex fluorescent
base copper micrornases are available in
ls format which requires agents um
filling into the containers protocol
editing
um i recommend you to please fill the
containers in the proper way as per
manual
we have the option of 30 ml containers 7
ml container
6 ml containers and especially for the
6ml containers
if you're just loading just what you
need for that specific run
do not forget the to factor the dead
volume
which would be 600 microliters so you
need to put in that
6 ml container whatever you need plus a
600 microliter
an important thing to know about the
leica system is that you can delay the
start of a run
so you can have it finish at whatever
time
and day you want um we do recommend you
however that when it's
finished to um basically uh
take the slides out and cover sleep
cover sleep then as soon as possible
because you don't want to lose
your counter stain and this is pretty
much
it uh thank you very much for attending
the webinar i'm now going to hand it to
damian cockfield and have a nice day
hello my name is damian cockfield i'm
the bond product manager
out of leica biosystems melbourne i'm
responsible for the
bond research and bond clinical systems
and uh i've also in my previous roles in
leica acted as a
laboratory scientist as well as project
manager and actually worked
directly with acd on the rna scope
technology
my talk is a bit of an extrapolation of
where the first two talks finished
i'll talk about about the rna-scape
workflow on bond rx
and the benefits of full automation to
your research
the bond rx research data from leica buy
systems
helps drive reefs helps researchers
drive their biomarker application
discoveries forward
by providing the quality and flexibility
uh worse than enabling the automation of
ihc
and ish emerging tests whilst the talks
from jyothi and andrea are more focused
on the explore your ideas phase
this talk will focus on how automation
can accelerate your research program
through the benefits of automation
but first let's take a step back in uh
to why we're talking about rna detection
in
in tissue dna and genes code for
everything that our body develops good
or bad
dna is the blueprint for life and that
blueprint is for making proteins
so through a process of gene expression
the genic
information is transcribed from dna to
rna and then translated to messenger rna
there's this mrna that instructs the
synthesis of protein
protein being the normal target for hc
is where the bulk of the work
in research and diagnostics on tissue
has been done until recently
so why rna and why detect in situ
using rna probes there are over 30 000
markers available with the
acd-rna ish technology opening up a
plethora of opportunities to discover
new information
about what is occurring within tissue
rna markers can
fulfill a need where antibodies may be
ineffective
or not available chimeric proteins for
an example
or more importantly with today viral
markers like covert 19 being of real
interest
and this follows on the back of market
acceptance of using rna scope for other
viral targets like hpv probes
so why we want to detect rna in situ
it's pretty clear
cellular context is vital to a biomarker
clinical
to a biomarker's clinical revel
relevance and
mrna gives clues as to what's happening
in the tissue at the time of excision
but why rna over dna or protein
applications is not so obvious
and largely that's because rna ish has
been an inferior test
for many years but that's no longer the
case
and rna ish bridges the gap between dna
and protein in the cell and allows
researchers to see the current state of
what is happening in tissue
yrna scope as a solution was made pretty
clear in the previous two talks
at the end of the day it comes down to
an increased confidence in your results
namely around specificity sensitivity
and the
ability to visualize the resulting
outputs
due to the proprietary technology only
the target signal is amplified
this combined with background
suppression ensures target specific
binding
the sensitivity of the assay allows for
detection of single rna molecules
in single cells as punctate dots in
their morphological context which can be
easily visualized with standard
microscopes and then quantified manually
digitally scanned on products like the
apira gt450
and quantified with the imperio rna-ish
image analysis algorithms
rna scope as an in-situ hybridization
technology
based on unique probe design and sorry
rna scope is
an in-situ hybridization technology
based on a unique
probe design and signal signal
amplification method
the technology has the sensitivity to
detect most genes in situ
as well as simultaneously quantify
multiple rna transcripts
but as in situ assay rna scope
assay involves permanencing properly
prepared samples to allow complementary
oligoprobes to bind to the rna target of
interest
the specific specific signal is
amplified
using the double z probe system which is
subsequently detected and quantified
the assay is extremely universal as well
as rapid and scalable
overall the technology is broadly
applicable for the detection of any
expressed biomarker and tissue
here is the workflow for the rna scope
assay
slides are baked and de-waxed then
pre-treatments are applied following the
rnscope probe hybridization
multiple rounds of amplification
chromogenic conversion and counter stain
manually this process is quite long and
has to be done
over two days separated across days with
pre-staining and post staining
this workflow doesn't show the
additional washers and labor time
required
but those of you experienced in ihc
initiating will note that this test will
benefit heavily from automation as you
can load your test slides onto bond rx
at the end of the day
and let it run everything overnight and
take off the complete sample in the
morning
as mentioned in the previous talks the
rns go product range comes in a range of
formats
manual semi-automated and fully
automated
automation with the bond rx provides you
with the ability to run slides overnight
so you're not wasting
your day on manual applications it
provides the ability to run up to 30
slides
the same test type or run parallel
multiple applications
like dna rna and ihc all together
and finally the bond rx and the unique
cover tile system
protects your samples and allows for
consistent processing
time after time
and here are the the two fully automated
products on bond rx the rna scope 2.5
lsx brown and red kits as you can see
the reagents within the kit are all
barcoded
so you just have to scan each of the
barcodes and bond rx will know exactly
what the kit is
that's it no decanting no problem
reagents just scan and load
the so first off we have the rna scope
2.5
lsx brown kit so uh the kits
are all ruo labeled or research use only
they all come in that a
ready to use format they are arranged in
a two tray
system with detection and amplification
reagents
each of the kits are 60 slides and
account for 15 different staining runs
on the research system
the brown kit uses the same dab in
hematoxylin that is also used in the
bond refined kit
so those of you who already use bond
will
see that it has that similar in look and
feel to make it easier for you to
to assess the red kit
has a similar format with the 60 slides
requiring batching of four slides or
more
and really with lung being the
an area of interest for covert 19 red
detection may be more appropriate
detection system for some of those
research applications
as it provides a color contrast between
the sort of brownie black pigment that
you sometimes
see in lung tissue so both of these
applications
can be ran overnight
the key with automation isn't just about
automating the steps of staining but
it's also making the interactions with
the system
simple and enjoyable for you the user
that simplicity though
can't be at the cost of flexibility
especially for researchers who require
the freedom to optimize
rnsco 2.5 lsx comes with pre-configured
protocols to allow you to plug and play
your reagents
and tests so that you can be up and
running straight away with the option of
pre-loaded
heat retrieval protocols as well as
enzyme retrieval protocols to provide
retrieval flexibility based on your
tissue samples
added to that the open protocol system
allows you the flexibility to adjust
your protocols as needed
but having user products myself i know
they work pretty well out of the box
an information i hope you've been able
to get a glimpse of how rna scope and
bond rx work together
to provide a path for your research
broad adoption of new technologies and
targets
comes comes when the barrier to adoption
is low or the return on invest
on on effort is high automation of bunda
rna scope
sorry automation of rna scope on bond rx
and the great range of compatible probes
like the covert 19 probes provided by
acd helps take a niche manual test
utilized by highly skilled and
potentially time poor researchers
to our simple easy to use solution that
you can trust
so you can focus on the results and not
the application
thank you
thank you diori andrea and damian for
your informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
of your questions as we have time for i
think we have time for about one or two
so um andrea can
you do i hc or if on the leica together
with
rna scope
yes hi uh the answer is yes
you can uh we generally do rna scope
first
and then we do immunofluorescence or
removalistic chemistry
and as you can do both on an automated
fashion on the lycra bond
wonderful um and jody this one's for you
why is the scientist research on reese's
macchias instead of ferrets for covid19
um hi sabrina so i believe the question
was more related to the paper that was
discussed
uh that paperwork had come out early
during the covet 19 outbreak
in 2019 where a lot of other animal
models were not studied
that's why the focus was more on racist
macaque models
but we have seen an uptick of
publications in a lot of other models
due to our rapid probe design ability to
design the probe for any kinds of
species if that answers the question
yes thank you so much and thank you
again teori andrea and damian
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank our
speakers for their time today
and their important research we would
also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsors like
biosystems and biotechnique for
underwriting today's educational webcast
you can view this webinar on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for
replay that is all for now until next
time
goodbye